our life has been completely
uh changed since our daughter's death it
was in the sweat lodge
where it all went wrong hot rocks doused
with water creating steam and
temperatures well past 100 degrees
his instructions on the fifth day before
they go into that sweat lodge
he's telling them these signs of heat
stroke
were monikers of success there was a
doctor in 2008 who had told his staff
that if he continued to do this he would
kill somebody
he revived i believe three people the
year before
the year before that one person had been
revived
in 2000 in 2007 someone
had permanent brain damage and was
convinced that it was his fault
that he didn't believe enough he knew
that there was danger involved in this
but he is
either doesn't care or is delusional
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
throwback thursday today we're talking
about the wannabe tony robbins
who got three people killed in what was
one of the worst
self-help industry tragedies of all time
and today
we are talking to the mother of one of
the victims because this story
needs to be told so far we've heard lies
we've heard narcissism we've heard
from the psychopaths involved but we
haven't really
heard from the true victims so
that's what this episode is all about
welcome to throwback thursday
guys this is all about by the way
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
this is all about
learning from the lessons of the past
right this is what
uh throwback thursday is about talk
about scammers from all to learn lessons
for today and that's exactly what we're
doing guys this whole episode is being
made because
i heard about james arthur ray if you
guys don't know who this guy is he was
one of these self-help guys a la
tony robbins you know he was like that
type he was trying to be
a mix of you know several different
gurus at once
like a little bit of deepak chopra your
greatest spiritual calling is to find
your purpose
in this lifetime and to pursue it and to
do it with excellence
to fall so in love with what you do and
so in love
with what you're a part of that the
lines blur
and a little bit of tony robbins like a
little bit of the spiritual a little bit
of the wealth all that kind of stuff and
he was trying to
rise to the top of the seminar circuit
by any means
necessary now in 2009
three people died at his hand or i
should say
because of the things he set up he set
up a sweat lodge
uh challenge or you know it was part of
a spiritual warrior journey retreat
whatever that cost a lot of money people
came
thinking that this man is uh you know
responsible he's someone you can
trust and eventually that trust was
betrayed when three of them
died james arthur ray was sentenced for
involuntary or
sorry negligent homicide and he later
got out after 20 months
he got a cnn documentary out of it and
in that documentary
again this is the reason i'm making this
video in that documentary
they interview james ray they interview
james ray's
like family members but you know who
they don't interview do you know who
they don't talk to
are the family members who we're gonna
talk to today
of the people who uh died in that sweat
lodge and i think
it's so important you know i'm often
accused stephen you only show one side
of the story
no this industry shows one side of the
story these documentaries
show one side of the story because
that's what
sells having someone on who lost their
daughter doesn't
sell so the same way talking to some
narcissistic
and by the way i'm not a psychologist
it's just my opinion some narcissistic
guru
cells so without further ado
we're going to talk to the mother
because right now james arthur is back
he's back on the
seminar streets right he's back selling
stuff on youtube
he wants to get you in this is after he
got convicted for this
he wants to he's going back to selling
and i wanted to hear from the mother
and tell the full story on what happened
in those days
our life has been completely
changed since our daughter's death i had
gone with her to a james
ray event in march of 2009
i understood why she was taken with him
i i think his teachings resonated with
her
she made an investment uh she felt like
she was investing in her future
how much was that it was almost ten
thousand dollars
and she never told me before she signed
up because i know i'm
cheap you know she would have she knows
she would have gotten some pushback from
me on that one
we were so blown away
that kirby died there were 60 people in
that
sweat lodge tent which was the
culminating activity of a five-day
retreat with james arthur ray
we couldn't understand what had really
happened
because she was strong and she was not
suggestible
you know as her mom i can tell you she
came out
knowing what she wanted you know so
uh and the more i thought about this the
more
i kept thinking james ray i believe
had gotten to a point in his career
where he corrupted himself over his love
of power and money
this sweat lodge was not done in the
native american tradition it was set up
like a heat
challenge my daughter responded
to challenge james ray said throughout
that week
you must play full-on and kirby was the
kind of person who played full-on
from the time she was born this is a
common
thread by the way this idea of you come
to these retreats they tell you you're
going to push yourself you're going to
do things you never thought possible
maybe you'll even do a firewalk with
tony robbins maybe you'll
push it even farther james right always
wanted to push it farther
so this kind of stuff is not a one-off
in this industry this is a recurring
problem where these life coaches these
gurus put themselves in positions of
power
with absolutely no oversight and the
more we learned about what happened in
those five days
that led us into really looking at more
of what goes on in the self-help
industry
and we felt a moral responsibility to
tell people there's danger out there
you know one thing that he said that
absolutely made me want to crawl out of
my skin
was he called it heroic the deaths
of these three people you know i think
it's really important
for me to communicate that james shore
liz newman and kirby brown or heroes
they're not victims they really believed
in something
as a mother what
how do you respond to somebody who's
saying that
number one your daughter chose somehow
chose this
putting them in a position of uh
subservience and shaming people who
didn't agree with him
uh so that people were afraid to uh
talk encouraging no sleep and
then isolating them so that they
couldn't process some of what they were
doing with each other
either i think it's really worth pausing
here
and taking a look at some of the extreme
tactics
that go on at some of these strange and
unregulated retreats right where people
are supposed to be
improving themselves it can border on
the very
very strange take a listen it got even
more strange she says when james ray
organized a game
about death based in part on the movie
the last
samurai james his role was god
so he wore white robes and he was god
and no one was allowed to talk to god
you were dressed up as an angel
i was an angel of death and i had black
lipstick on black around my eyes
you know we all had grim reaper costumes
on what was the point of this game
um i'm not uh to live with honor to die
with honor maybe
so by the time we get to
his instructions on the fifth day before
they go into that sweat lodge
he's telling them that these signs of
heat stroke
were monikers of success that when they
felt disoriented when they felt nauseous
when they thought they were going to
pass out
these are all signs that they're on the
verge of a breakthrough
and just push through this had already
happened because
i've heard him on interviews multiple
interviews saying
you know we didn't know the the event
was dangerous
basically we now know but we didn't know
before these deaths
and i am fully responsible it was my
event it was my team
it was my choice to do what we know now
as a dangerous exercise
there was a doctor in 2008 who had told
his staff
that if he continued to do this he would
kill somebody
he revived i believe three people the
year before
the year before that one person had been
revived
in 2000 in 2007 someone
had permanent brain damage and was
convinced that it was his fault
that he didn't believe enough so
he knew that there was danger involved
in this
but he is either doesn't care
or is delusional this this disgusts me
because one thing he says
is he characterized i believe it was you
he was talking about as his number one
critic
and i'm thinking yeah you don't say
it's your number one critic you jackass
so i mean excuse my french but
it is so upsetting to me that he's still
out there pitching as if he's taken
accountability he keeps saying i've
taken responsibility i picked up his
ebook
the first thing is i've taken
responsibility sometimes people have a
tendency
particularly the the trolls and haters
to misinterpret that i'm trying to
sidestep
responsibility and i will never do that
and as the leader i'm responsible
you know when something goes sideways in
your business there's only one person in
the crosshairs
i don't see that but then again i'm not
a victim in this case
you are do you see that he's taking
responsibility
no not at all he he keeps saying i'm
sorry this happened
well i'm sorry this happened too
this is my daughter that i have to live
without he served 20 months in prison
and we've been serving a sentence for
over 11 years
without kirby if he had gone to prison
and came out saying i now realize
that the mind control tactics that i
used that what i
did without proper knowledge i've
learned
the whole thing would have turned out
differently
but instead he says these people
i think in the documentary says i'm the
only person in history
who uh had to go to jail and and lose my
freedom and lose my business because of
other people's decisions
it wasn't her decision to die
because she was unconscious in that tent
and could not have left and he knew she
was unconscious
and did nothing james shore pulled out
someone who was unconscious
right in front of james ray at the end
of the seventh round
saved her life went back in the tent to
get kirby because he was next to her
said to james ray we need help back here
and he's for the third time said we will
take care of it at the end of the round
and he walked out and at the end of that
round james shaw and kirby brown were
dead
james shore was trying to save your
daughter's life yes
they were found holding hands and he had
been saying to her keep breathing her
keep breathing
this man heard that he was
like 10 feet away from them frankly i
knew
as much if not more about them than some
of their nearest and dearest friends and
loved ones
and so it broke my heart man i mean
because now he's the victim of this
that's how he's portraying himself and
when i sat and watched
enlighten us to watch him be on stage
crying because he lost his three good
friends
that made me want to throw up because he
left them
in the tent yes back
when he knew that they were
there and they also paid him 10 000 they
were his clients
and that's it i found out that my
daughter was dead
by a trooper who came to my door to
inform me
he didn't call me no one from his
organization called me
i didn't hear from this man until five
days later
what did he say when he fir what do you
what did he say when he first talked to
you
how are you i said i'm in shock
and he said i am too i i i can't
i i can't understand how this could have
happened
and i said cooperate with the local
police
who are investigating this so that they
can
help you understand what happened
he said i am and we had been talking to
the local police so we knew he hadn't
yeah didn't he run i thought he ran away
from the crowd like he
he famously fled he left in the middle
of the night he never spoke to anybody
there was an allegation that you left
the scene pretty quickly
and just disappeared is that true and if
so why did you leave so fast
you know pierce i wish i could say that
i was enlightened enough to
not have any impulse from
self-preservation
i'm not and what what to me was even
more egregious
he he had a call a conference call with
a number of the participants
the next wednesday this happened on a
thursday night the next wednesday there
was a conference call with a number of
participants
and in that call someone said
well there was a channeler there who
said
kirby and james were having so much fun
outside of their bodies they decided not
to return
and he did not say anything and he
allowed that to become
the myth of what happened they chose
their deaths it was their time they
chose it
i think it's disrespectful for them to
be portrayed as victims
because they really believe in what
they're doing and
in life as an entrepreneur you've got to
be willing to give everything you have
and it's difficult it's not easy the
fact that he's still
pitching this stuff he's learned nothing
and he's allowed to just with impunity
go out and
you know you know he's still the sweat
lodge guy but he tries to use it as
oh it was a growth opportunity for me
that's how the documentary ends by the
way
it's an infomercial for him he goes it
was a growth opportunity
for me and i hope i can resonate with
everyone out there
that if i could go through something so
traumatic again
other people dying um that you can maybe
learn from my
lessons in life uh if you could say
anything to james arthur ray
i mean there's no way he can ever put
these pieces back together
but if there is something you know he
could do
to just close this story what would it
be
that you would find to be you know
that's all you can do
would it be stopping stopping his
practice shutting down
telling people what he did is there
anything at this point
what would you tell him well i think i
would
tell him that i'm going to continue to
tell people this the truth of what
happened because
he hasn't been able to do that i'm also
going to tell him
that i forgive him because i'm not
going to live with unforgiveness and
bitterness and thoughts of revenge for
the rest of my life
i'm not going to do that but that
doesn't mean that i trust him
or that i trust that he would keep other
people safe
because he hasn't learned anything from
what happened
and what i would hope for him is that
maybe someday he will learn
what he really did and somehow be able
to understand that
get out of the self-help industry where
you know you're a phenomenal salesman
okay so so so go go somewhere else
but in this industry where people you
you're dealing with their emotional
health you're dealing with their
physical health go away
just just go away you know we will
continue
to have seek safely the goal of which is
to
empower the seeker to help people
understand
uh give them tools so that they can have
a
more efficacious journey a safer journey
as they try to improve themselves
because
we're always looking to improve
ourselves that's part of the human
condition
you know it's part of the human
therapist we're always going to do that
and and people do that in lots of
different ways
but people need to know that there's
danger in this industry
even though there are great people in
this industry
and how did how to discern the
difference
between those who would harm you and
those who will really help you
well i'm totally inspired by you uh
even the fact that you could forgive
this man is
simultaneously unfathomable but also
so um
i don't know if inspirational is the
right word but i'm very touched by your
graciousness and
you know your unbelievable heart for
people who are out there seeking
you and your husband have set up a
basically a non-profit 501c3
that is called seeksafely.org you can go
check it out right now
it's all about seekers who want to find
their way through this kind of
thorny underbrush of the self-help
industry
i want to thank you for coming on and
sharing this experience with um
so many i hope you guys go check out uh
the website seeksafely.org
and uh you know also that book i'll link
that below
thank you for coming on and sharing your
experience i hope that
others can learn from um your daughter
thank you very much thanks
see you guys all right that's it
uh let me stop recording and um
[Music]
[Music]